and the award for the best achievement
and sound have two of the film's
brightest new stars sandy Duncan and
Michael York
can you remember sandy how you felt the
first time you had your own voice play
back my voice yes I can remember to tell
you the truth I couldn't believe it I
thought I was somebody else
well I'm very glad you're not when Sam
came to the move is it ruin the great
many careers and yes it gave films a
whole new dimension and now for the best
achievement in sound the nominees are
diamonds are forever
Gordon McCallum John Mitchell Alfred J
Overton Fiddler on the Roof again Gordon
K McCallum and David Hilliard the French
Connection
Theodore Soderbergh and Christopher
Newman touch
Richard Portland and Jack Solomon Mary
Queen of Scots Bob Jones and John
Aldridge and the winner is winners are
Gordon Jamie Caleb K McCallum the David
Hilliard for fiddler on the roof
accepting the award for Gordon F
McCallum and David Hilliard mr.
McCullough
thank you ladies and gentlemen what can
I say this is a most wonderful moment in
my life
thank you all members of the Academy for
voting for fiddler it's a film of which
I shall always be proud I think it's a
wonderful film it was great working with
Johnny Williams and under Norman Jewison
wonderful sympathetic direction and
sorry that David Hilliard is not here to
join me in this wonderful moment thank
you
to present the award for the best
performance by an actress in a
supporting role the beautiful and
beguiling Raquel Welch and the tough cop
who never sang for his father Gene
Hackman